a marshmallow and peanut fridge cake
perfect for a picnic
first things first we have to slowly
melt the chocolate mmm that's good
I'm gonna break up the chocolate right
in there next butter goes it double
tablespoons of golden syrup it's so good
if we melt chocolate too quickly it
starts to separate and destroy the best
and safest way to melt chocolate is
always use herb and Marie but I'm gonna
keep a really close eye on mine and heat
it over a super low heat this stunning
little cake has your favorites in there
digestives yeah hands in there and give
them like that one time ago and crush
what's the one thing that you love about
picnic I love eating outside especially
on a nice summery day not so much in the
wind today no that's gonna be the
crunchy part of our fridge cake and it's
called a fridge cake because you can sit
in the fridge or you can freeze it yeah
peanuts in please can you use it without
peanuts if you're allergic to peanuts oh
you can do yeah definitely no more these
little babies berries numbers from their
marshmallow my favorite okay they're so
bright honey why'd you love marshmallows
so much cuz that's a squidgy I give that
a nice mix up chocolates melting nicely
okay I want you to pour that in and I'll
mix it nice and gently slowly slowly
seriously nice
now touch more please hmm yeah isn't it
good give that old mixer daddy please
then they were mounting that we're gonna
line the trace this is quite easy to
make because you don't have to bake it
mm-hmm you just set it yeah I want you
to start pushing it into the corners
please with your fingers just laying it
a nice and flat
all right so nice and marshmallow easy
mmm there to get food spatula
okay look how delicious does that look
really good
if I could eat it right now I couldn't
fill it's not set so when that sets
okay they'll get nice and firm then we
can cut it into little bars little
squares triangles triangles push good
but the important part pushing it down
and so we can slice it and the more we
push the phanie we can slice okay
and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut bridge cake Donna
Polly Tilly really guys ready and if
you're going on a picnic with a crowd
though he's ready for picnic Wow do the
whole lot as an alfresco feast